what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
debauchery treachery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in let's get
started all right guys today we are
going to be talking about Gisele
Bundchen and Tom Brady so Giselle and
Tom divorced last year now there are a
couple warning signs that a woman is
going to leave your ass yes I know the
women will say there's no patterns
they're just doing this but I'll tell
you number one is if she out earns you
bad idea now I know what you're thinking
Pearl can it work ever yes it can but
not usually because most women have a
modern mindset where they think they are
better than a man because they out earn
him even though typically the the man
brings more value to Society for example
Giselle was a supermodel now is sitting
pretty taking pictures as valuable to
society as throwing a football well I
guess maybe they're both entertainment
but one is significantly harder let's
just call a spade a spade let's just
call it what it is America's favorite
pastime
America's favorite quarterback of all
time has done a bit more to get there
than Giselle who's sitting taking
pictures now the feminists will come in
and say walking down a Runway is really
hard
taking pictures is really hard and well
I'm not discounting that but I mean when
you think about football versus taking
pictures
one may be paid more but can we just
call it what it is
now she did divorce his ass and right
after the divorce she was seen with her
kids karate instructor in Italy
vacationing having a rendezvous
Tom Brady says nothing
but this is what women do all right
women will divorce your ass and get mad
when you move on because they think
you're just gonna be under their spell
for a lifetime and when you say okay see
you lady and you get a younger hotter
tighter model like he did
they get a bit mad now I am actually
happy for him because I heard he was
dating Kim Kardashian now it seems like
he is not this is all speculation guys
just so you know but apparently he has a
new romance with
Arena Shank
if I said her name wrong I'm sorry this
is who I am a beautiful younger woman
you know and they always say the second
wife is an upgrade I don't know what to
tell you guys and this is why a lot of
guys get red pilled because Tom Brady
was everything a chick would want
Christian Guy family man not out there
partying left and right I don't think
he's a known cheater at least
yet yet
when
yet he can do everything right and his
wife will still divorce his ass women
are never happy you can give a woman
everything she wants and she will never
be happy now why is it rumored that they
divorced oh he was
uh working on his career too much but
the funny thing is if the men were not
working on their careers we would not
want them anyway and what you can see is
this is a control tactic of modern women
women are not meant to control men
women are not meant to control their
husbands their husbands are supposed to
follow their purpose and the women are
supposed to follow but we have
Brainwashed the media into convincing
women that we need our emotional needs
met that we need
um that he has to spend a certain amount
of time at home with us that we get to
dictate what is acceptable for him to be
a family man and then we'll keep our
last names which is not traditional and
well divorce his ass
and then when he moves on we'll cry
about it and my question is why is it
that she was able to move on
and Tom Brady said nothing about it but
yet when he moves on she's got an issue
women want to have their cake and eat it
too they want her their own money
but they don't want to depend on a man
but they want a man that's traditional
it's like which one is it they want a
man that's a family man but when he
spends too much time at home then
they're not happy because you know we
grew apart he didn't follow his purpose
whatever it is or he will become a
better person he will grow and and
become the best version of himself and
Chase his dreams his goals and what do
the women get mad about then he's not
home enough but the real problem when we
hear all of this stuff and I want you
once you guys start hearing this you
cannot hear it when you start hearing
women say he didn't meet my emotional
needs he spent too much time at work
that is the indication or my favorite
one I did so much for him that is the
indication of a woman that one keeps
score
um that will resent you if she has to
give up anything and a girl that
competes with her husband
and a woman that is controlling there is
nothing worse than a controlling woman
why because as women it's like we don't
even know what we want one day we want
this one day we want that one day we
feel this one day we feel that it's like
we are not meant to be in control
yet
Society tells us that my favorite thing
that you should get wisdom from your
wife
that you should have an equal say that
your husband has to ask you your husband
isn't supposed to ask you permission
you're not supposed to make decisions
together he's supposed to make the
decision he can consult you but this
idea that we have an equal say in
relationships I actually think it is
mean to tell women that I really do
because you're telling women we're
supposed to have a role that we are not
supposed to have you are telling women
that we are equal when we are not and I
think it is mean to push women
who won let's just be honest we're
basically like big kids right that can
just be propagated and like you can push
us to do things like
um I I think it's mean to tell us to be
in a role that we are not meant to be in
instead of being honest
and you know following your husband so
that's that's my two cent women want the
best of everything they want to marry a
superstar world famous football player
and they also want him to be faithful
and then when he's faithful
now he's not home enough it's like the
men can't win the men literally cannot
win